why are we not doing that yeah it just
blows your mind that we're not doing
this and and the simple reason why we're
not doing it is because it has very
little sort of public awareness the
story is that you're saying is basically
we're throwing a hell of a lot of money
at a wide range of things because we
want to deliver all things to all men
and here are 35 billion 12 things you
can focus on to actually make a big
impact so let's talk about that what are
the biggest things that we actually
should be looking at Beyond one obvious
thing is maternal and newborn Health uh
so uh one thing that surprised me was so
many moms are still dying from
childbirth so about 300 000 moms die
each and every year in this world and
they needn't do that in childbirth uh
2.3 million kids die each and every year
in the first 28 days in their life on
Earth that's just terrible and again
totally totally unnecessary so much of
this is because there is complications
during birth and there's no materials to
to handle that so the mom has uh
preeclampsia or eclampsia basically high
blood pressure and she bleeds out uh we
know how to fix that we fix that
routinely in the rich world we should
make sure moms get into institutional
birth give give birth in institutions
instead of just doing it at home
so that there is an opportunity to treat
her if things go wrong likewise you know
and again I didn't know this at all so
most kids that come out of mom just
start breathing right away about 80 so
15 percent need a slap in the back to
get going and then they start breathing
that's fine but even in rich countries
about five percent of all kids just
don't breathe wow so you need to start
giving you you need to push in air into
their lungs and then and then they go
and then they survive right so and of
course course we just do that in rich
countries isn't that rocket science you
just need a simple uh hand pump I mean
in rich countries we have something more
fancy because we can't have such easy
things right but but in in in in the
poor part of War you just often don't
have this hand pump it costs 65 for each
of these hand pumps it works for
probably three years and in that in that
time you could probably save about 25
kids 65 25 kids
why are we not doing that and again
that you know I don't want everybody to
rush out and do a gofund just for this
hand pump it's about getting all of
these things so you know for instance uh
uh disinfectants yeah you'd imagine
that's a good idea to have disinfectants
and on the surfaces in your hospital
Wing but again we don't and and so a lot
of places do but you know about a fifth
don't we should make sure that that has
it there and so the point with this
argument is really just to tell people
if we focus more on maternal and newborn
Health that's by making sure that the
women come in uh to institutional bursts
so about uh two-thirds are doing it now
we want almost all in institutional
birth and that these institutions
actually have midwives that they have
disinfectants that they have this hand
pump these very very simple things World
Health Organization has a whole list of
this if you did all of that it would
cost about five billion dollars a year
so not nothing
but then you could save 166 000 moms
each and every year and you could save
1.2 million kids each and every year
it's just yeah it just blows your mind
that we're not doing this and and the
simple reason why we're not doing it is
because it has very little sort of
public awareness I don't know have you
guys ever seen the uh this is the Monty
Python skit uh skid with uh the machine
that says playing no no you have it's a
a a meaning of life you oh God you've
got to say that anyway so uh they're
they're they're these doctors uh uh in
in an operating room or something uh and
they have all these machines and they're
all totally excited about the machines
and the uh and the manager of the
hospital comes in he's then they oh
let's show him the machine that says
pling which is apparently the most
expensive machine in the hospital so
everybody's very excited about it and
then at one point John Cleese goes
still something missing man
hmm
[Music]
patient yes where's the patient patient
they're so excited about these expensive
machines that they forget that this is
about the woman and you know she it's
funny and she get just neglected all the
time and they want to emphasize the
machine that says playing right I mean
and and you know obviously it's a
character and and you know I'm not
saying that all doctors are like that
but doctors probably rather would have
an MRI scanner than they would one of
those hand pumps right because you know
it's fun to go to a conference and say
yes we have this you know this new MRI
scanner 2000 or whatever it's called but
you know this hand pump uh old old stuff
but it's actually this hand pump that'll
help save uh 25 kids because in some
ways you know when you've got people in
sitting around a room in the U.N and
they're all very intelligent they almost
desire complex Solutions because
it's more grandiose isn't it than
something as simple and as prosaic as a
hand pump yes but but it's not that they
haven't promised also to fix this right
because they promise everything but but
the point is that when you're promising
everything you have no direction if you
have 169 priorities you have no
priorities right yeah and if you promise
everything you inevitably leave it to
people to say hmm would I rather have a
cheap hat pump that nobody cares about
oh would I like a lot of expensive stuff
and a new hospital wing and you know all
these other things uh so you know the
the
as we almost inevitably end up doing
stuff that's less effective not because
people are bad but because they have
lots of other incentives apart from you
know doing the best things first and so
that's why I think by making this book
and by forcing everyone to sort of
confront the fact that there are some
incredibly effective things we can do it
becomes a little harder to not do that
first
foreign